oh my god how weird how weird is this
first of all I gotta say I'm loving the
blonde hair but is this like a classic
quarantine made me do it honestly I have
been wanting to go belong forever like I
kept putting it off because it's so
scary to make such a big change like
that but now I don't ever want to be
brunette again like I yes like I
literally am obsessed with the blonde
and I love it and I just want to like
keep my hair light and I actually it
just works better but then again my mind
changes with hair like every 20 minutes
like you say that not but it could
change like by the end of the summer
literally so let's talk about VidCon
because obviously it's gonna look a lot
different this year but you are still
doing something really special for the
panel and it involves your dad which is
so cool what do you guys have planned
for your VidCon panel we're so excited
well my dad and I he's been my creative
go-to man since day one and so I think
we just want to talk about that whole
process and just being a parent with a
kid who's doing something that maybe is
a little bit different and how to
support that child also you know I'm
gonna talk about my journey in general
and just kind of you know have him there
to be able to help me tell the story and
I I'm really excited because he's just
like so cool and I you know loved him so
much and so it's nice to have you know
people that you love and care about
involved in in your work life as well
your dad he has his own painting channel
on YouTube as well and I'm thinking like
what do we have to do to get like a
Chamberland family reality series is
that something you guys would ever
consider because I would watch Oh God I
mean I don't think we do anything that
interesting to be on it's like if you
really want to know what the whole
series would look like it would be my
dad painting and it would be me hanging
out with my friends and playing for
tonight and filming YouTube videos like
I really wish I did crazy stuff but I
feel like we're such a simple or not a
simple family but we're definitely we're
pretty chill were chill family
okay then I just need like a Netflix
docu-series or something the only
because like one maybe one just
documentary film because it's not
there's you know there's not many
parents that one would support their kid
going full-time on YouTube let alone
like move to a different city at such a
young age I mean what was the biggest
piece of advice her dad gave you when
you started this whole YouTube journey I
think his main message I mean he's given
me so so much advice just like
constantly from the beginning but I
think his main thing was just make
things that you know you love and be
completely yourself don't put on a
character people don't want to see that
you know they want to see you for you
and don't change for anybody and you
know make sure that I have a life
outside of the internet that is a
filling as well yeah that's been like
the most important advice that I've
needed to remind myself of constantly
because you know it's so easy to get
wrapped up in it and I think you hand
telling me that constantly has really
helped me keep my mind in the right spot
and stay sane it seems like he also has
always just kind of like inspired your
creativity - I read that you he said
that you grew up in a creative cottage
and there was just like musical
instruments did not supplies and all of
this stuff I feel like your judge maybe
build its own like tick tock house and
start like you know you know just start
molding some other Emma Chamberland like
in the digital space whatever do her
family to that I think is like it's
really interesting I mean I'm an only
child and he is the most me to him
we're very independent like we don't
like clutter space which is so funny
which is why I mean I've never had a
roommate and I'm you know except for my
parents and I think that my dad and I
would both lose our minds if we had
other people living in our space so I
don't know how the whole tick-tock house
thing would work um although the idea of
it sounds amazing maybe like a one-week
little vacay where you know like
somewhere to wash up a little Hawaiian
moment we can you know
rent some instruments we can all in
cameras and make something but I don't
on a day-to-day basis I think my dad and
I would would freak out
hey what's up know why I'm like on
camera all the time
you have built this entire career long
before how like those kind of tick-tock
and creative houses existed you feel
like those collectives for lack of a
better word help or hurt or career I
think I mean I love I'm not a huge
collaborator I do most of the things I
do by myself just cuz that's how I work
best but I think that you know
everything is so situational and I've
seen so much success and it seems like
so much fun
come from these different houses and
groups of people that are together and I
think that collaborating can really help
with creativity and I know I'm
constantly collaborating behind the
scenes with my dad and that's kind of a
no to person but not necessarily
everybody has that in their family so I
think that having a group of people who
understand you know the space and
understand all that around you is really
important and not only you know create
things with but also to help keep you
grounded when you're kind of like when
your brains all over the place it's kind
of amazing that you have your dad to
lean on for that kind of stuff because
obviously like I mentioned you're such a
boss now and you're your CEO and
building this huge brand and up next is
the ideal planner I feel like you know
your videos we get a glimpse into your
mindset but I felt like now we actually
see it in this planner because there's
just so many different things in it I
want to get it there's puzzles and like
pages to color how much fun was it to
really sink your teeth into this
particular project it was really fun I
I'm super particular about aesthetics of
things most planners I think can be kind
of cliche and like the things like the
prompts that they have and things like
that
I'm like you know what are your goals
for the month and stuff like that so and
I think of those things are important
but I think that it's an in-order tap
you want to actually participate in
those types of things it has to be
worded the right way and I think having
the you know aesthetic of the planner
itself be inviting all that's super
important and so it was a long process
it took
longer than I expected and it took also
a lot more words than I expected which
was totally fine but it was just you
know it was interesting to see how love
went into every single page like a you
know not one page didn't have my eyes on
it
seventy times so it was a very intimate
project and I I'm really proud of how I
came out and I'm excited for people that
organize with me I love it where there's
some ideas for the pages that just you
had to let go that didn't get to make it
into the actual planner but you have so
many yes definitely like there was a lot
of different like I know my dad never
brainstorming um different types like
funny kind of like more almost like a
like a workbook school workbook page
looks like kind of a joke if that makes
sense like we had this whole idea about
like doing um like it was like a math
thing or something that would have been
funny but then I was like there's just
no way to know like who's reading this
and like what you know what there's like
certain things oh yeah did not do
because it was like it might not be fun
for like a broader audience like even if
it's like or it might not translate
properly like this the way that we want
it to so there's like things like that
that we cut out but um it was kind of
like natural selection it was like the
best the best things ended up in the
baby yes yeah so dope I was talking
about your coffee before we signed on
and like it is so good first of all but
second of all like you could take it
anywhere and so I'm obsessed with your
coffee brand too and obviously your fans
know that you're a huge coffee addict
but like what's the craziest thing that
Emma Chamberland has ever done super
caffeinated there's a lot there is a lot
Wow I will one time actually this was a
really long time ago I I do is like
National Coffee Day I think and I
decided I was gonna go and get as many
copies as I could in one day and I think
I may have had like five to eight or
something I'm well you know like have
heart palpitations by the end of today
because I'm having so much caffeine
when I went home after filming that
video I was just being the most annoying
little nightmare to my mom and like shut
up just like could not stop talking like
just talking about the most random
things her she just wanted me to stop
and go into my room who was i tortured
her for a little bit and you know she
got over it I'm trying to think I think
everything that I do is so caffeinated
that I am almost even now if that's
possible cuz you have natural energy too
don't you on top of like the caffeine
intake for sure I mean I think I'm
starting to settle down as I'm growing
older which is weird because I'm seeing
myself have less energy um but I think
it's actually better because now I can
drink the same amount of coffee but kind
of be at a normal level rather than yes
so I'm like now that my energy and I'm
kind of more chill now it's like great I
can just go back up to that level with
coffee and then they'd all evened out
and everything's still fun I feel like
you're just probably feeling more chill
these days cuz we have to stay home like
everything has gotta slow down you know
but say you know we get to get a
quarantine soon who is someone you would
love to get a cup of coffee with any
like any artist I mean you know more see
from the Smiths mm okay of the Smiths
is so much I need I actually don't
really know anything about Morrissey
really at all which is like literally
nothing about him I just know that I
love his music
so that would be fun any musicians that
I'm into I'd love it have them sing to
me or whatever ha ha ha
now we're talking Slyke come get a cup
of coffee with me ball so bring your
guitar thank you so much there's the
podcast there's merch the plan or the
coffee what's next for Emma Chamberlain
I love like you furring to you Emma
Chamberlain I gotta say your full-name
but what is next in your world god I
honestly I think what I'm super excited
about is being able to I mean obvious I
don't know when this is gonna happen so
I'm you know for now we're gonna stay
home and be responsible but when I'm so
excited to kind of be able to travel
again and like those experiences and you
know hopefully see some more fashion
shows and document all that get glammed
up I love that well thing that's what
I'm really looking forward to to be
honest and I'm excited for those things
to start up again but for now I dream
about them and and we're you know
luckily I've quite a few things to
distract me right now the coffee and the
thinner and the VidCon and all those
things are amazing distractions and I'm
excited about all of those for now but
cannot wait to hit the road a little bit
yeah
[Music]